so we have here is tropical 5 for the
xbox one it's taken us a while but we
finally are supporting our friends and
longtime fans who switch from xbox 360
to to the xbox one so to give those
folks have and over if you haven't seen
it before this is ace full-on city
builder based on the Isle of tropico
this is a fictitious tropical island and
it's run by the fictitious dictator el
Presidente as al presidente your goal is
to build out this little colony gildan
so generates money increase the wealth
and prosperity of tropic hands as well
as fill up your secret Swiss bank
account because you're an evil dictator
and you need money so this is your right
hand command panel tomo hence the
penultimate edition so this is a basic
tutorial kind of just gives you an idea
of what's going on you know gives you
explains how we've managed to do such a
sort of complicated city builder here on
console hammer man who has been the
makers of tropical for traffic 05
tropical modern times and done all the
console versions I'm done an excellent
job as any xbox 360 person will tell you
and we've like I they've actually read
down the ctrl C even be better on Xbox
one I'm this is just at oriole level
you'll start off here you know you've
been assigned an island of tropico from
you know as a colony you've got to get
through your tutorial points and stuff
like yes you know gives you an idea of
like all right let's take a look at our
little buildings you know see what's
going on you know this is a true city
builder I mean you actually have to
manage each building each Road each
function each facility make sure all the
productions working oh and we gotta
speed up time here good job and ultimo
is you're sick of fantic totally
respects you would do anything fun over
you second in command which is perfect
for a dictator
yeah we got to go over here looks like
little my knee guys infrastructure is
always important any Cindy build a
person will tell you um you know we've
got a something over here just a little
dirt someone let you know what's going
on time for an official inspection let's
take a look with X I've got everything
down here you can go in and actually
start firing people you can see what the
people's you know overall happiness
viewers stuff that they're thinking and
anyone's talking smack about yeah you
can even do this down to the tiniest
level like what's that person thinking
about all right can I Brian also you
know hey you can kill him ride home
banishing discredit him you can play
this any way you want you can be as
benevolent a dictator as you like yeah
but at the same time oh we got to build
a road right all right well roads always
fun let me get this one tutorial map out
of the way please give you a little bit
of lace
nothing new here so we've got you know
once again we're using of the nice
radial menu that people are familiar
with that as like I said has worked out
really well see you know let's change
our camera angle let's get a road so our
minds boom roads looking good cool now
the teamsters going to run in start
doing some mining you go and then we're
done with that and a good job you now
you start exporting iron this seems a
basic ships will come in and as a matter
of fact here's a guy right here coming
on in and you are an island nation so
you have to build commerce you have to
build textiles you have to build farms
you have to build facilities also in a
slightly political you have to make
alignments with rotted Russia and ever
so the thing about tropical fried is
this is starting off about like roughly
roughly 200 years ago sort of an actual
banana republic time so what you'll see
here is you know here's all the things
that you can build right now a dog a
teamster office construction stuff like
that you've got multiple things but
you'll have the things that will unlock
later in the eras and what tropical 5 is
done that is different than tropical
forests is there's different eras so
instead of being the best in one time
frame you actually have to be the best
then you name a successor of all the
people that you can choose from in
tropico to sort of run tropico in your
stead so you created dynasty so it goes
you know from you know here we go from
modern times then we go into the cold
war world wars which is world war one
era and then into ya know finally up
into modern times you have to be
successful all the way through now you
can get voted out of power because for
some reason you you know I've decided to
create a constitution which is actually
pretty funny there's a lot of things
that you can do in here since we're all
resources you know a lot of things that
everyone in tropico is familiar with
these are the things that you can
research and we haven't put down a
library yet this is going to give you an
idea of how you want to play this so you
can be obviously research things to help
her productivity your planks your longer
mill
one of them is as you saw d who we have
the Constitution so like I said why
would you want to be a dictator have a
constitution the ability to vote makes
people happy that if the boat doesn't go
your way you can still be a dictator and
just disband it or you can bribe your
way to win here we are in sandbox mode
sandbox mode includes a lot of dlc it's
all five of the first DLC packs from the
pc it might be an exaggeration of course
as I'm not even certain that Switzerland
can be seen from space yeah and the true
tropico sense of tongue-in-cheek humors
in here here we are at the island you
know you pulled out to modern times at
any point in this party got cruise ship
stuff like that I'm going to keep going
and keep going and say and we've got a
nuclear reactor let's see you know what
let's build an economy hotel right near
that guy because nobody doesn't want to
sit next to a hotel that's right next to
a nuclear reactor this is good airplanes
come in and that's kind of it so one of
the things though that we have for the
xbox is we have five new maps that are
Xbox exclusives so we created those for
sandbox mode and those will be on the
disc for every 0 on as long as with the
first five DLCs and the refined controls
then this is going to be 49 99 and will
be available on May twenty-fourth
you